[Music]
I welcome to Hannity tonight the
Democratic Party way out of control
they've declared war on a President of
the United States and of course driven
by a blind unyielding psychotic rage for
president Trump and Democrats and their
collaborators in the mob they will do
anything to smear slander but Smerch
President Trump and anybody that likes
the president that means they're really
attacking you we the American people so
make no mistake
all these holier-than-thou well dirtbags
to be very obvious here they have wanted
President Trump
impeached pretty much the very moment he
was sworn in and of course they just
haven't been able to come up with any
reason because he didn't do anything
wrong
Russia Russia Russian peach and peach
and peach collusion collusion stormy
stormy okay there weren't no high crimes
bribery misdemeanors no conspiracy no
obstruction of justice no cover-up at
all and tonight nothing has changed
Ukrainian story you know what the only
person that was there shaking down
Ukraine for anything with sleepy creepy
crazy joe 303 300 tourney's Jay Sekulow
Rudy Giuliani they will be here to weigh
in on all of this we have a studio
audience panel of experts
but first let's be clear and very clear
about one thing
Donald Trump is not going to be removed
from office
remember what congressman Al Green said
he goes yeah this is back in May we're
gonna have to impeach him because you
can't win at the ballot box so all of
the hysteria I know it's not a lot of
people upset over impeachment
impeachment in the end will be much to
do about nothing but unfortunately
Democrats Nancy Pelosi the Jerry Nadler
's the cowardly shifts the Maxine Waters
of the world they don't care what
happens to the country in the process
what have they done to make this a safer
more secure country create jobs more
prosperity for you we the American
people this is beyond a political stunt
this is a psychosis they can't escape
from the reality they lost in 2016 and
thankfully if they keep this up they
will lose badly in 2020
is this from a party that does not care
about truth I mean there's no objective
truth in their world facts justice
fairness none of that matters their only
concern is like a blood lust for
president Trump anybody that supports
the president president well we can't
say it any better than he has this they
have declared war they did it
somebody declares war there's only one
answer defeat them in the bout at the
ballot box take a look all right tonight
a perfect example of this madness and
sickness california congressman yeah the
Cowardly shift a president Trump calls
him little Adam Schiff and pencil
penciled next shift but his colleagues
refer to him as and we refer to as the
biggest liar in the US House of
Representatives
case in point yesterday he performed
what was a dramatic reading of the phone
call transcript between the president
and the Ukrainian president his
counterpart szalinski and the only
problem is Schiff made it up every
single word he made up and in other
words an official House hearing
featuring an Acting Director of National
Intelligence and this congressman Schiff
who's lied lied live been proven to lie
over and over again concocting his own
version of the call but out of thin air
we have the transcript he didn't have to
make it up he could have read the actual
transcript and by the way entered that
into the official record and after
getting called out for lying Welsh if
you referred his fake version of the
phone call a parody oh that's what that
is in Congress you know maybe he's right
now president Trump is now calling for
him to resign he tweeted out quote Adam
Schiff totally made up my conversation
with the Ukrainian president and read it
to Congress and millions he must resign
he must be investigated and he's been
doing this now for over two years he's a
pretty sick man
as per usual Schiff has no regrets for
trying to purposely mislead the American
public he could have read it the way it
was written down the way the transcript
happened no he
needed to embellish it because there's
nothing in the real transcript take a
look do you regret the what you call the
parody the use of those phrases during
the course of your opening statement no
I think everyone understood and my GOP
colleagues may faint otherwise that was
mocking the president's conduct but make
no mistake about this what the president
did is up the utmost gravity and and the
utmost seriousness
because it involves such a fundamental
betrayal of his oath all right this is
not the first time shift caught in a lie
before the mullah report was even
released memory claimed that he had
direct evidence of Trump Russia
collusion lie he told that lie over and
over again also claiming other evidence
of colluding was hiding in plain sight
that's another lie and of course there
is an actual recording of shift yep he's
the one guy that believed you was
colluding with a Russian and it's taped
and by the way he's like what is the
nature of the compromise naked naked
piece of the Trump okay did Vladimir see
this divided Amir see it okay but
they'll call Adam is he the the naked
pictures yeah he was trying to get dirt
on Donald Trump and collude to impact
American elections and while Schiff is
engaging in his fraudulent activity well
the Democratic speaker in name only
Pelosi she's floating a brand-new
baseless conspiracy theory according to
Pelosi this whole Ukrainian issue Russia
is behind president Trump's phone call
with the Ukrainian president Wow
you know earth Pelosi take a look I
think Russia has a handedness by the way
you know but we saw with the Russian and
disruption of our election last time
their interference a hundred percent
confidence of the intelligence community
high confidence in the intelligence
community Russians disrupted our
election that was wrong
the integrity of our elections is
central to our democracy was Russia's
fault of course
now finally Nancy the Russia collusion
we have four separate investigation a
house Intel investigation bipartisan
Senate investigation the FBI nine-month
investigation the Muller three-year
witch-hunt no evidence of any collusion
no obstruction maybe someone should
remind Nancy the Democrats false phony
feigned moral outrage now it's shifted
to Ukraine we're on to another talking
point Nancy you got to keep up with your
crowd now tonight we're also learning
new details that cast very serious doubt
on the claims of the so-called
whistleblower that isn't a whistleblower
look at this New York Times reporter Ken
Vogel saying that the country of Ukraine
had no idea the US aid was yes with held
during the Trump phone call in question
they didn't know till a month later and
keep in mind the Inspector General found
that the whistleblower had political
bias against Trump and remember he or
she who's not really a whistleblower is
represented by a law firm that pays for
anti Trump leaks and the so-called
whistleblower who has not had no direct
knowledge of any phone call
that's called hearsay Your Honor I
object
hearsay sustained that's how that would
work in a court of law
third hand accounts publicly available
in the media well what good is that
that's not a whistleblower now we have
the president and his attorney Jay
Sekulow they are rightly claiming this
person did not act alone in fact Jay
Sekulow believes that a law firm drafted
that complaint certainly looks like it
to me doesn't seem like a whistleblower
but also one question today is well the
New York Times report former CIA back to
the CIA oh do we have spies again within
our own government spying on the
President of the United States abusing
the powerful tools of intelligence that
we give them we entrusted them to keep
us safe now regardless of who wrote this
complaint its claims are bogus
there was no quid pro quo zip you can
read it yourself not the made-up version
no misconduct nothing only person that's
involved in a quid pro quo you want to
say so
that would be yeah Joe 303 300 and his
son that had no qualifications when it
comes to Ukraine no experience energy
oil gas no experience he makes millions
and he made billions in China same thing
no no background experience in in
private equity banking none whatsoever
the we confined but he goes with his
father flies on Air Force two and what
do you know he's got a billion five in
contracts it's a great life if your
dad's the vice president I guess and
speaker in name only Nancy Pelosi is
apparently living in her alternative
reality even further take a look I think
we have to stay focused as far as the
public is concerned on the fact that the
President of the United States use
taxpayer dollars to shake down the
leader of another country for his own
political game you know what we can't
have
that's a quid pro quo Nancy care to
comment on this let's take a look we're
not going to give you the million
dollars sorry you're not the president
the president said I said call
you're not getting I said you're not
getting a billion I'm gonna be leaving
to here I think it was watch six hours I
looked I said we've in six hours
if the prosecutors not fired you're not
getting the money son of a B the guy
that's investigating my son I didn't
have experience to make all that money
he got fired because I threatened it
with old tax dollars the billion dollars
we were gonna give Ukraine and I'm in
charge of Ukraine okay that's Biden
bragging about breaking the law and a
quid pro quo tonight there is now
credible evidence that the former vice
president leveraged that billion dollars
you saw the tape of your money to get
the Ukrainian prosecutor fired all to
protect his son remember he was warned
by the New York Times and The New York
Times told them yeah they're
investigating your son II at another
warning he tried previously to get the
guy fired now we just withheld a billion
dollars and said you got six hours why
would a vice-president of the United
States of America want a Ukrainian
prosecutor fired now just for a second
because the media won't touch it let's
imagine for a second that that was
Donald Trump bragging that he withheld a
billion dollars until they fired a
prosecutor that was doing business with
his sons or his daughters I don't think
the media would ever stop until Donald
Trump got in trouble for that little gig
and by the way Don junior Eric Ivanka
Andy Tiffani mayhem instead the mob is
barely covering that real scandal
surrounding Joe and Honora Biden we
won't stop will get you the truth as we
always do a top Ukrainian prosecutor was
investigating Maurice Moe Holdings that
is the oil and gas company that paid
hunter Biden millions of dollars to
serve on their board and consult with no
experience of natural gas no experience
with Ukraine and after learning that his
son was about to be interviewed by the
top prosecutor well that's when well
sleepy Joe 303 302 manded the prosecutor
be fired Biden says he wanted the
prosecutor gone because he was corrupt
we have a brand new report from
investigative reporter John Sullivan
Biden's story does not hold water
he has 450 brand new documents pay
of it interviews numerous Ukrainian
officials and it appears the prosecutor
was fired because of personal reasons
rounding a former vice-president by the
way he has a sworn affidavit to that
very fact